and it is not good news number of lives
lost 230 technically up from yesterday
even allowing for the Sunday reporting
but it is painful painful news for all
New Yorkers and will remember those
families and our thoughts and prayers
there's no doubt that we're coming down
the mountain the only question is what
trail we take what path we take coming
down the mountain how fast is that the
climb continue does the decline continue
and that is purely a function of what we
do none of this is preordained none of
this is decided by any factor other than
our own behavior you tell me how well
New Yorkers socially compile comply with
distancing etc and I'll tell you what
that infection rate is doing it's that
simple and everything we have done thus
far has worked and that's why the
numbers coming down but you tell me what
we do today and tomorrow and I'll tell
you the infection rate in the next few
days what we've said from the beginning
is the key is testing and tracing and
isolating it's very hard to do it's easy
to say no one has ever done this before
we've never put this kind of testing
regimen in place industry-wide we've
never had a tracing operation that's
anywhere near this magnitude we've never
done isolation quarantine that's never
happened before
but it's we do what we have to do and
this is what we have to do to monitor
the infection rate and to control it
then that's what we're doing we laid out
a very specific reopening plan yesterday
we studied all the state's plans we've
studied reopening plans of countries
around the world we incorporated all the
best practices I think we probably have
the most specific plan for metrics and
measuring to make these decisions and
it's basically a mathematical formula if
you look at that reopening plan and I
think that's
that's the way we should do it and
proceed this is about following the data
learning the lessons listening to the
experts following the science and it's
about being smart
everybody's emotional we're getting more
emotional there's more stress there's
more anxiety there's more pressure on
all of us we want to get on with life we
want a paycheck we want to make sure our
job is there but it's still a time to be
smart right we don't act emotionally we
act based on logic in fact in science
that's how we make policy but we have to
remind ourselves everyday because the
pressure is to just respond to the
emotion and there's also no doubt that
we're going through a devastating and
costly moment in history it's costly on
every level number of lives lost the
economic impact the personal impact
substance abuse has gone up domestic
violence has gone up mental health
issues have gone up so we have paid a
very high price for what we're going
through but the hope is that we learn
from it and that we are the better for
it right we endured the pain let's make
sure we benefit from the game and this
is also true and people can understand
this as a life lesson
you know you get as old as I am you go
through some tough periods in life and
that's a fact that is going to happen
you live life long enough you will go
through a difficult period I've gone
through more than my share but you take
those periods and you try to learn from
them and you try to grow right that's
the best you can do with it what what
did what can you learn so when you move
forward you're the better for it and we
do that as a society also that's the
concept of build back better we don't
want to go through all of this and
replace what was there before replacing
what was there before as a starting
point we want to replace but we want to
improve and we want to be better for
this experience and we want to build
back better
we were smart enough to do that as a
country as a state after 9/11 we went
through pain we came back stronger
you could argue more United as a country
more United as a state more aware of our
vulnerabilities and yes greatest country
on the planet greatest state in the
nation was our opinion but we were
vulnerable to terrorist attacks okay so
we learned from it
we got stronger we got better and we
we've incorporated security into our
life in a way that was unimaginable
before 9/11 hurricanes sandy superstorm
sandy devastated thousands of lives
billions of dollars in damage we built
back and we built back better than we
were before we didn't replace what was
we improved almost everything that we
learned during that time our housing
construction is different our power grid
is different our infrastructure is
different so you go through these
situations and you learn and that's what
we have to do here we have to have a
better public health system we should
never go through this again what we went
through with the hospitals we what we
went through with PPE staff shortages
that can never happen again
how we use telemedicine we have to learn
and we have to grow it was vital to what
we did here we have to make sure we're
better at it our public transportation
system we're learning tonight we're
going to shut down the subways for the
first time in history why because they
have to be disinfected who ever heard of
disinfecting a subway car
well now you learn you have to disinfect
subway cars figure out how to do it so
you can say to people who use the
subways don't worry it's safe right
that's a starting point for public
transportation and one of the areas we
can really learn from is education we've
all been talking about tell education
virtual education remote education and
there's a lot that can be done you know
the
model of everybody goes and sits in a
classroom and the teacher is in front of
that classroom and teaches that class
and you do that all across the city all
across the state all these buildings all
these physical classrooms why with all
the technology you have and we've been
exploring different alternatives with
technology right we have classrooms in
this state that have technology where
they're talking to students on Long
Island with a teacher from Staten Island
with students from around the world
participating with technology hearing
that one teacher and if you look at the
technology it looks like all these
different students are in one classroom
all right well let's learn from that and
let's learn from this experience we did
a lot of remote learning frankly we
weren't prepared to do it we didn't have
advanced warning but we did what we had
to do and and the teachers and the
education system did a great job but
there's more we can do we're still
working on providing some students with
the technology with the tablets etc some
teachers needed training and they
weren't ready for it well let's take
this experience and really learn how we
can do differently and better with our
education system in terms of technology
in virtual education etc and that's
something we're actively working on
through this process so it's not about
just reopening schools when we are
reopening schools let's open a better
school and let's open a smarter
education system and I want to thank the
Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation we'll
be working with them on this project
Bill Gates is a visionary in many ways
and his ideas and thoughts on technology
and education he's spoken about for
years but I think we now have a moment
in history where we can actually
incorporate and advance those ideas
right when this change
to a society because we all talk about
change in advancement but really we like
control right and we like the status quo
and it's hard to change the status quo
but you get moments in history where
people say okay I'm ready
I'm ready for change I get it I think
this is one of those moments and I think
education as well as other topics as a
topic where people will say look I I've
been reflecting I've been thinking I
learned a lot we all learned a lot about
how vulnerable we are and how much we
have to do and let's start talking about
really revolutionising education and
it's about time one point I want to make
about reopening not just in this state
but all across this nation there's a
conversation that is going on about
reopening that we are not necessarily
explicit about but which is very
important there's a question that is
being debated right under the surface
and the decision was decisions we make
on reopening are really profound
decisions and the fundamental question
which we're not articulating is how much
is a human life worth how much do we
think a human life is worth there's a
cost of staying closed know that
economic cost personal cost there is
also a cost of reopening quickly either
option has a cost you stay closed
there's a cost you reopen quickly and
there's a cost
the faster we reopen the lower the
economic cost but the higher the human
cost because the more lives lost that my
friends is the decision we are really
making
what is that balance what is that
trade-off because it is very real if you
now look at the projection models of how
many lives will be lost
you'll notice they changed recently why
did they change and they went up
dramatically why because now they're
factoring in the reopening plans and the
reopening schedules that states are
announcing the federal government's
estimate federal government's estimate
FEMA has increased from twenty five
thousand to two hundred thousand the
number of daily cases by June think
about that increase the IH MA which is a
foundation model supported by gates
which is the preferred model by the
White House when they were projecting
deaths by August fourth they projected
in early April sixty thousand deaths
they projected mid April sixty thousand
three hundred deaths actually a little
lower their new projection is a hundred
thirty-four thousand deaths how did it
go from sixty thousand deaths to one
hundred and thirty-four thousand deaths
this is the model which the White House
relies on when the director of the
Institute was asked why those revisions
happened the director said rising
mobility in most US states as well as
the easing of social distancing measures
expected in thirty-one states by May
eleventh indicating that growing
contacts among people will promote
his mission of the coronavirus that's a
very nice way of saying when you
accelerate the reopening you will have
more people coming in contact with other
people you're relaxing social distancing
the more people in contact with other
people
the higher the infection rate of the
spread of the virus the more people get
infected the more people die we know
that and that's why the projection
models are going up there's a cost of
staying closed there's also a cost of
reopening quickly that is the hard truth
that we are all dealing with and let's
be honest about it and let's be open
about it and let's not camouflage the
actual terms of the discussion that
we're having and the question comes back
to how much is a human life worth you
see that projection model go from 25 to
200,000 cases from FEMA you see the
number of deaths go from 60,000 to 134
thousand how much is a human life worth
that's the real discussion that no one
is admitting openly or freely but we
should to me I say cost of human life a
human life is priceless to read our
reopening plan doesn't have a trade off
our reopening plan says you monitor the
data you monitor the transmission rate
you monitor the hospitalization rate you
monitor the death rate if it goes up you
have a quote-unquote circuit breaker you
stop you close the valve on reopening
but it is a conversation that we should
have openly hard conversation painful
conversation
a controversial conversation yes all of
the above but it's also the right
conversation because those are the
decisions were making also as we're
going through this it's important that
our leadership be factual and productive
and United because this is a time when
government has to work and government on
all levels has to work and the federal
government has to work and it has to
work now better than it is worked in the
past you know all the craziness that
we've watched in Washington all the
politics that we've seen in Washington
all the dysfunction that we've seen in
Washington now it is unacceptable
because what government does today will
literally determine how many people live
and how many died and that's not
hyperbolic and that's not overly
dramatic that is just a fact that
federal government has to be able to
pass legislation to pass legislation it
has to be on a bipartisan basis
you have the Congress the house is
controlled by Democrats the Senate is
controlled by Republicans unless you get
a bipartisan agreement you're not going
to pass legislation if you don't pass
legislation the federal government does
not work if the federal government
doesn't work it makes it virtually
impossible for state governments to work
if I can't work then local governments
can't work this is not something that a
state can control
well the governors are in charge
governors are in charge I can only be in
charge to the extent I have the
resources and the means and that comes
from the federal government not just for
New York but for every state in this
country so that federal government has
to work and the legislation that they
pass
is important and they have to pass
legislation and that only happens on a
bipartisan basis there was no choice
well just the Democrats can do it well
just the Republicans can do it they
cannot it takes two to tango it takes
two houses to pass a bill and one is
Democratic and one is Republican so the
facts are important president gave an
interview as reported in the New York
Post blue state coronavirus bailouts are
unfair to Republicans bailouts this is
the topic of whether or not the federal
government should provide aid to state
governments and it's been a discussion
for weeks federal government passed
legislation in the past that helped
Airlines help small businesses helped
hotels great great they haven't provided
any aid to state and local governments
well why is that important it's the
state and local governments that fund
police fire education teachers health
care workers if you starve the states
how do you expect the states to be able
to fund this entire reopening plan well
the governors are in charge but the
states are in dire financial
circumstances because our economy
suffered when all the businesses shut
down so the debate now is well it's the
blue states that have the coronavirus
okay New York they call a blue state
California they call a blue state and
the Republicans are saying we don't want
to give money to the blue states first
of all this is not a blue state issue
every state
coronavirus cases and it's not just
democratic states that have an economic
shortfall Republican states have an
economic shortfall well it's the
mismanagement of blue states for decades
that they now want us to bail out that's
just not a fact it is not a fact first
of all no blue state was asking for a
bailout before this coronavirus I wasn't
asking for anything from the federal
government before the coronavirus and by
the way the federal government wasn't
giving New York anything for years
everything they were doing was negative
to New York then comes the corona virus
our economy stops because we shut it
down now we have a thirteen billion
dollar deficit because we stopped the
economy so what we're asking every state
is asking because of the corona virus we
need financial help in restarting the
economy and that's what we're asking for
from the federal government how you call
that a bailout which is such a loaded
word such a rhetorical hyperbolic word
it's a bailout there's no bailout
because of the corona virus this nation
has been impacted and States have been
impacted because the states make up the
nation and we need financial help
because of the coronavirus situation and
this is not any mismanagement by the
states if anything the mismanagement has
been on behalf of the federal government
and that's where the mismanagement has
gone back decades senator Moynihan God
rest his soul
New York senator great man said decades
ago that New York has been continually
shortchanged by the federal government
why because we have always given them
more money than they gave us back right
how does the federal government work the
federal government collects taxes and
puts it all in a pot and then takes
money from that federal pot and gives it
back to the states every year New York
State has put more money into that
federal pot then the federal government
has given back every year for decades
and that is just a fact also you want to
try to divide divide divide the facts
are it's the democratic states which
happened to have now high coronavirus
content which actually have put in more
money than the Republican states who are
now saying why should we bail out the
democratic states the democratic states
have been supporting them for years New
York every year 29 million dollars more
paid in that it gets out New Jersey also
a high coronavirus state 18 billion
dollars more every year then it gives
out Massachusetts Connecticut California
and then you look at the Republicans who
now say well we don't want to help the
Democratic states they are actually the
states that have been taking more every
year Virginia Maryland Kentucky senator
Mitch McConnell is Kentucky 37 billion
dollars more every year Alabama Florida
everything is about Florida why because
it's a swing state and we're in an
election year I get it Florida gets 30
billion dollars more every year then it
puts in what are you talking about
fairness equity bailout
you look at where we've been over the
past five years we've paid it in a
hundred and sixteen billion dollars more
than we gave back you want to be fair
just give New York back the money you
took and it'd be a hundred and sixteen
billion dollars who gives and who takes
we know those facts and we know the
numbers but look this whole discussion
that Senator McConnell is raising that
some senators are raising this is
counterproductive
and it will lead to defeat for all of us
you need a bipartisan bill to pass you
go down this path of partisanship and
politics you will never pass a bill and
if you never pass legislation you'll
never get this economy back on its feet
so you go down this path of division you
will defeat all of us because we're all
in the same boat
there is no separating us still the
United States of America in this
partisanship we have to turn the page I
know it's how Washington operates I know
it's how Opera Washington has been
operating for many years but we have to
stop and we have to change and you do
need a totally different mindset it
can't be it's you versus me it has to be
we right we the people if you don't get
back to we and you think about a
collective interest you're going to
defeat us all because it can't happen
and you have to get out of this Democrat
Republican it's red or blue it's not red
or blue it's red white and blue this
coronavirus doesn't pick Democrats or
Republicans it doesn't kill Democrats or
Republicans
it kills Americans the virus is less
discriminating and more of an equalizer
then the lens that we're viewing the
virus through and if we can't get past
this now when can we ever get past it
you have a national crisis you have a
national outbreak a national epidemic
killing thousands of people you can't
put your politics aside even now even
today families have fights yes family
have fights somebody's gonna die and the
family is still gonna carry forward
these silly fights from years ago nobody
even remembers how they started if
there's ever time to come together it's
at a moment of crisis and this is a
moment of crisis and we always
understood and the great ones always
told us that it won't work this way a
house divided against itself cannot
stand
you want to be a leader you want to go
down in the history books as someone who
stood up and did the right thing well
then remember what made us great in the
first place and that's what a great
leader would do also last point each of
us must do our part talk about
government government government yeah
government has a lot to do I understand
that fully citizens also have a role to
play you know who's going to keep
yourself you're going to keep yourself
safe you know who's going to keep your
family safe you're going to keep your
family safe and you know who's going to
keep each other safe each one of us
keeps the other safe every person has a
responsibility here social
responsibility and that's what wearing a
mask is all about just wear a mask it's
the smart thing to do it's also the
right thing to do right thing to do
and all this complexity there is still a
right thing
you still know what's the right thing to
do and the wrong thing to do maybe right
thing is in New York expression I don't
think so you know what the right thing
to do is nobody has to tell you what the
right thing to do is the right thing to
do is to wear a mask because it's not
about you it's about my health you wear
a mask to protect me I wear a mask to
protect you and wearing a mask is not
the greatest intrusion I do not
understand why people think it's such a
burden to wear a mask and look 99
percent of the people do it it's the one
percent of the people who don't do it
right that's what we're talking about
and we were talking about this last
night and I was expressing my
frustration why some people just don't
get it and what this has been about from
day one this whole exercise and where I
started this on day one all these things
we've done nobody's doing these things
because government told them to do it
right I'm first government governor in
the history of the state of New York to
say we're closing businesses to say you
must be quarantined no governor has ever
said that how do I enforce that I can't
I can't
how do you enforce making 19 million
people stay at home I can't I said from
day one I can give the facts to New
Yorkers but then New Yorkers have to
decide and agree that it makes sense
given the facts and agree to do it and
New Yorkers have agreed to do it all of
these things closing schools closing
businesses stay at home socially
distancing so now we're we're a mask and
I was saying last night I don't
understand why this wear a mask is so
hard mariah suggested
it may be the way I'm communicating it
I'm just not effectively communicating
don't laugh
well first of all this is a common
refrain in my house from my daughters
that it's me and my lack of ability to
communicate effectively its first ad and
I'm guilty I have no doubt I am guilty I
am a bad communicator and that I haven't
been communicating the rationale for
wearing a mask effectively so I'm
open-minded I understand my weaknesses
and my flaws I'm a work in progress
we're all of work in progress I'm trying
to get better so my suggestion is look
why don't we ask New Yorkers to produce
an ad that the state could run on
explaining to New Yorkers why they
should wear a mask and the context and
the rationale and the health reasons and
the social responsibility and it's not
that big a deal maybe there's a better
way to communicate it and I have been
communicating it again 99% of the people
are doing it and it's great we're
talking about that 1% so maybe I just
haven't been persuasive or effective
enough in my communication skills so I
said to Mariah great idea we'll ask New
Yorkers produce an ad 30-second ad they
submit it mariah is going to be an
unofficial adviser with the Department
of Health pick the five best put them
online let New Yorkers pick the best ad
state we'll run that ad it'll say on the
bottom produced by whoever won the
competition they'll get a lot of acclaim
they'll go on to be big creative experts
and maybe we'll have an ad that that
communicates this better than I have
been able to communicate it to date so
I'm excited about that
and Mariah is going to help on that and
take it on as a project and I'm excited
about that at no cost to the people of
the state of New York she would be a
volunteer the boyfriend can try to put
in he could submit a possible ed for
consideration the boyfriend will lose
but he could submit an ad because I'm
still governor and that's what we're
going to do Mariah do you want to add
anything or did I explain it clearly in
my flawed communication modality we'll
be providing more information in the
next few days but if you are interested
you can go to wear a mask dot n y dot
gov see sometimes I communicate
sometimes I communicate effectively but
you're not alone in criticizing my
communication skills many of the people
in this room would agree with you
and we are New York TouchSmart United
disciplined and loved it
questions comment on it looks like
there's some new reporting regarding
nursing homes and it would increase the
total by about 1700 in terms of total
deaths
does that count towards the official
tally are they in a different category
how's that being reported out you have
I'll ask you Melissa to explain us
because I don't know the details frankly
you have two categories confirmed deaths
and then probable or presumed deaths and
they list numbers in both categories
some people combine the two confirmed
deaths and presumed deaths and have one
number some people keep them separate
and then they're often reported
separately or the reported together but
that has been going on for a while but
Jim is there is that accurate that's a
cure government like we reported in the
past we asked the nursing homes to
provide updated information they
originally provided about
3,100 total deaths the confirmed deaths
of those are actually 2,100 that gets an
added to the official count we are
counting both the presumed and confirmed
but the confirmed guests are the one
we're running in the official tally
other localities are submitting
unconfirmed best but we want to confirm
those things as much as we can but now
we're putting up both categories of
people can clearly see because some of
the facilities were reporting both
together and it was difficult to tease
out so we've asked them to report
clearly that line both confirmed and
presumed which is something this week
they issued a statement saying there had
been 98 deaths but the official
reporting shows less than that something
in the 60s does it not count hospital
deaths in other words if someone goes
from a facility to a hospital is that
then counted differently those get
reported in the hospitalization deaths
the Isabella situation they reported 60
but in actuality it's 21 confirmed
deaths and the remaining being presumed
which will have to officially try to
confirm one way or another so it is in
line with keeping with what they were
sending before but we've asked those
facilities that update which they have
just to be clear I would take all of
these numbers now with a grain of salt
look we're just saying the confirmed
deaths you know what that means what is
a presumed death meaning right
we presume it how do you presume it to
be coronavirus also the at-home deaths
non hospital non nursing home deaths
just at home deaths when do they when do
you actually get all the numbers on
those and how do you confirm all those
deaths as attributed to coronavirus so I
would just have a caveat with all of
these I think they're going to change
over time Wireless steps taken earlier
to protect such a vulnerable population
as you look back now and knowing that
this virus was going to be around for a
while are there things they're
mechanisms
can be done differently so when people
are sick in the nursing homes they go to
the hospital and stay in the hospital
well the go in the hospital and stay in
the hospital well first your basic point
is is right the nursing homes we said
from day one are the most vulnerable
place because it's old people senior
people who are the vulnerable population
in a congregate setting and that's how
we were this nation was introduced to
the virus with a Seattle nursing home
right so and it was true around the
world also what can you do better going
forward I I don't know that's something
we're studying we're also doing an
investigation with the Attorney General
to look at it we did some very harsh
things here that frankly I wasn't even
comfortable with but the health experts
insisted no visitors to a nursing home
for two months no visitors how do you do
that because all it takes is one person
to walk in test the staff PPE you know
you do everything you can but if there's
anything else we can learn from and do
we will do you have people who get sick
in the nursing home sometimes they
transported to a hospital
that's up to the experts in the nursing
home if that's helpful if they're in the
hospital we also need hospital beds
right it's not like we can turn
hospitals into nursing homes once a
person is better the person has to go
somewhere they don't have to go back to
the nursing home by the way the way the
nursing home operates they make a
determination if they can provide the
best care for the person if the nursing
home says I can't provide care for this
person then the nursing home
must transfer the resident or call the
Department of Health and say this person
should be referred somewhere else I
can't take care of this person
we have kovat facility hope it only
facilities for that can take people from
nursing homes the nursing home has to
make the decision so if the hospital
calls and says I want to send back a
person who had kovat but is now better
to the nursing home
if the nursing home doesn't think they
can take them they shouldn't I know they
have to do is say no and tell the
Department of Health and that person
will go somewhere else so it really
comes down to that nursing home has to
know what its limits are who can provide
care for and who can't provide care for
and we have alternatives but we have to
get it from that nursing home first
Melissa do you have anything to add no
actually Jim do you want to speak to
that I think the governor said it we've
had really aggressive measures in New
York State no visitors from the outside
which is a pretty aggressive measure
12-hour temperature checks on all staff
PPE requirements for all staff and as
the governor said the rules from the
federal government and the state are
clear you have to do separate cohorts
for kovat positive versus code the
negative not only for the residents but
also for the staff and if you cannot do
the regulations state specifically NYC
are our four eight seven point four and
four eight eight point four cannot admit
residents who are symptomatic unless the
facility's licensure certification
require on-site clinical staff capable
of attending to the medical needs of
symptomatic Ovid residents pursuant to
the instructions so it's clear and we've
made all we've made many facilities
available for kovat only it's up to the
facilities that call us to make sure we
can make that transfers happen
in the nursing home we've been working
directly the state this is a residential
requirement for the facility themselves
but facilities that have not have had
difficulty we have provided hundreds of
thousands if not millions of PPE to
nursing homes all across the state
including downstate hundreds of
thousands of gloves hundreds of
thousands of dago's face masks gowns so
we've been working to back through
something that's not actually a
requirement of the state to do but given
the crisis we have been providing that
infamous illa T's you know everybody was
the point that the nursing homes now we
knew the nursing homes were going to be
a target and whatever we do they will be
a target those nursing homes and I've
spoken to a number of them and staff
they are doing phenomenal work
we lost 230 people yesterday we didn't
lose 230 people to coronavirus because
we didn't do everything that we could do
we have the best health care system on
the planet I believe and our people are
doing everything they can do we have the
equipment we have the staff they're
doing everything they could do still 230
people died in a nursing home that
coronavirus if it figures out a way to
get in there and all it takes is one
person one staff person who doesn't have
a temperature was not symptomatic one
facility person one person who comes to
work on the air-conditioning system all
it takes is one person to bring that
virus in there and you do everything you
can but at the same time you can't do
everything right
say to people who say the metrics that
you laid out yesterday are unrealistic
and it will be places like New York to
be closed for a very long time possibly
until there's a vaccine and to the end
of reimagining what do you see the
subways looking like yeah the first on
the the metrics the metrics we didn't
create any metrics those are all best
practices most of the metrics are CDC
metrics the main metrics are from the
federal CDC so they are they're all
reasonable and come from reliable
sources quote-unquote experts in the
field to the extent there are experts in
this field because as we've learned the
experts have also been wrong but they
are metrics and they are measurements
and the alternative is well I don't want
to follow any measurements even if they
are the safe sane measurements because I
want to reopen yeah I understand that
that's the emotion over the logic right
so the question would become do you want
to reopen even if it is not safe to
reopen and that's the question I posed
and that is the question that we're
dealing with in society okay more people
will die I want to reopen anyway okay
how many more deaths are you willing to
sustained to reopen quickly 100 more
deaths 500 more deaths because there is
a cost of reopening there's a cost of
staying closed there's a cost of
reopening too quickly so let's be honest
about it
it's a trade-off and say to the American
people and say to the people of the
state of New York we can reopen tomorrow
if you want to reopen this is how many
more people will die
I hme model says we they adjusted from
134,000 nationwide based on what 31
states are doing if you're okay with
that you're okay with that
when will we reopen when it's safe you
tell me how fast that line comes down
how fast the decline I'll tell you when
we reopen it depends on what we do and
that's where we are when will the
subways reopen when the Penn well the
subways are open you mean when will they
reopen on the nighttime service oh the
reimagine look you can take precautions
on the subways but you know the socially
you can socially distance now on the
subway because the brighter strip is
down 92% but when the subway is up and
running I don't think would be possible
to stay six feet apart
you could wear masks you could do
sanitizer I don't know what the capacity
would go down yeah you've seen that in
countries around the world they reopened
because it's pressure to reopen the
numbers went sky-high and they
backtracked that's not ideal it's better
than seeing the numbers go through the
roof but it's not ideal the ideal is you
reopen in a controlled format that when
those numbers start to take up you've
been watching the numbers and then you
were just you're reopening right what
we've seen in other countries they went
to they went it was binary they opened
and then they closed more intelligent I
think with retrospect a moderated
modulated reopening so you can watch
those numbers right and you turn the
valve you watch the flow and you'll
watch the dials and as soon as you see
the dials move slow down on the flow
when do we hit the metrics in New York
City I don't know nobody can tell you it
depends how fast the decline continues
and how we control the spread of the
virus it's all in our control you tell
me our behavior our behavior is a direct
coefficient of the rate of ants in
affection it's what you do today you
don't wear a mask you wind up infecting
someone you know so we're in total
control of that number and we don't even
know the rate of decline right you can
factor out by the current rate but we
don't know how low it's going to go
that's why we watch the numbers every
day what's your reaction to that
president to try to get the two to tango
and have you considered waving yeah the
we're not in a position to provide
anymore subsidies right now because we
have a thirteen billion dollar deficit
so there's a lot of good things I would
like to do and if we get federal funding
we can do but it would be irresponsible
for me to sit here looking at a thirteen
billion dollar deficit and say I'm gonna
spend more money on when I can't even
pay the essential services if we don't
get money from Washington we can't fund
schools right so at the rate we want to
fund them so we are in dire financial
need the what would I want to say to the
president I get the politics of the
Senate I get Republican partisan
politics
I get Democratic partisan politics
I managed govern this state for over
eight years with a Democratic assembly
and a Republican Senate I understand the
polarization I dealt with it year after
year after year but we got the job done
we passed the budget on time every year
and that doesn't happen by playing to
the politics it happens when you rise
above the politics the president in my
opinion has to be the reasonable one
here he has to be the compromiser he
will not pass a piece of legislation
without the house without the Congress
that will not happen and you cannot ask
the Democrats and Nancy Pelosi speaker
Pelosi and our Democratic delegation
from this state to pass another piece of
legislation that doesn't take into
consideration the needs of this state we
went through this on the last bill they
passed I said to my congressional
delegation they're not coming to fund
state government's oh yes they said they
will they will they'll be reasonable I
said I don't believe it they passed the
last bill didn't have any state and
local funding and you know what now
they're saying they won't do it the the
congressional Democrats cannot pass a
bill that forces them to savage their
own States they can't so the president
is looking at a scenario where he either
is reasonable and bridges the gap or
they will not pass any legislation and
then he will have failed and this nation
will suffer and that is what the
president is looking
not been flagging cases of Kawasaki
syndrome my colleague Melissa Russo has
been reporting on this it's a coded like
syndrome that impacts children
Nassau County has 17 cases in the ICU I
think 40 cases overall the State Health
Department has not been providing an
update on this we're wondering where
that stands something that dr. Zucker
has been looking into melissa has been
sharing her reporting with me directly
and we'll have something on that
tomorrow just as a quick follow-up on
the MTA can you assure commuters that
24-hour service will resume can you
assure me yes when is the question you
tell me when the global pandemic is over
I'll tell you when the 24-hour service
presumes you go first no it's just when
the pandemic is not problematic to this
extent president he's also griping in
the New York Post in terms of the fact
that the two senators Senator Schumer
and Gillibrand have not called it you
know we see this from the present from
time to time it becomes personal for him
how much of the way do you think what's
going on now it's personal for him
versus politics do you think there's
some his feelings being hurt you hear a
lot about that you've managed him pretty
well in your relationship with just your
reaction to that it's always it's it's
all of the above right first on the
mismanagement of the state this state
was doing very very well before
coronavirus lower taxes highest number
of jobs in history we were doing great I
wasn't asking for a nickel from the
federal government and we weren't
getting anything from the federal
government so it has nothing to do with
decades of mismanagement the only
decades of mismanagement really is on
the federal side without inequity for
decades New York State has been
subsidizing the federal government for
decades that is a numerical fact it's
not an opinion it's not rhetoric it's
not hyperbole its effect in numbers
they're not
we put in more than we get out so that's
that on that issue the I don't even
think the president started this fight I
think this is the Republicans fight this
is the Republicans in the Senate are
saying we come from Republican states
why should we give any money to
democratic states which is just a really
selfish narrow isolationist divisive
partisan opinion right if New Yorkers
took that stand then nobody should have
paid federal taxes for the past 30 years
because we were giving them money right
and there was no crisis it was just an
annual we are a relatively rich state so
we give Florida 30 billion dollars every
year so that's where it started the
president now articulated that theory in
the post and if he is adopting that
theory that he also believes we
shouldn't help democratic states deal
with the coronavirus fallout I think it
is partisan it is divisive and it is
self-defeating because the Democrats in
the house cannot be fooled again and
they cannot pass a bill that doesn't
provide help to the people they
represent the congressional members from
New York cannot pass another bill that
does not provide help to the people they
represent they can't do that and then
come home and stand before the people
they represent so if the president
doesn't figure out how to bridge this
divide he will have no legislation and
if he doesn't have legislation he will
have fair
as a leader which is problematic on a
number of levels and more importantly
this nation will suffer so I think it is
a bad road for the president to go down
now as part of it personal with the
centre's look he has said to me one of
the main fights I had with the president
was on a program called salt it was a
tax change that ended state and local
tax deductibility which took this New
York incongruity where we give more than
we get back and it put it on steroids it
ended our deduction of state and local
taxes and it cost us 14 billion more
every year and that was a really
aggressive negative punitive action
against New York in my opinion it was
this partisanship it took more money
from the democratic states to give to
the Republican states that's what it did
solved and I had a clear disagreement
with the president about it on a number
of occasions and the president in
fairness back then said that the
senators hadn't fixed it and the senator
should have fixed it so this is a
long-running issue with him
would you tell us why Drita presumes the
best example from dealing with the
pandemic what plans
yeah we have studied just about every
plan that's been out there and more than
plans the experience you can go look at
what happened in Europe when they
reopened you can look at China when they
reopened and all of them to plus or
minus degree have seen some rebound of
the virus and the question is how big is
the rebound and can you manage that
rebound or is the rebound so high that
you have to go back to close down which
we've seen in other countries so it's
more learning from their experience
right somebody walks down the path you
have to walk down a path ask them what
they found when they walk down the path
we we're learning from the benefit of
that experience I don't think we said
anything about Brazil's plan
specifically beyond just the
experimental let's take one more
I'm having to drop through so just
wondering if you'll extend your
executive order pass me good team that
does not require them to get a knee
replacement
yes today thank you I'm going to work
you safe guys thank you very much